it's starting to get chilly outside if
you've ever wished you could have a
little jacket for your dick you're in
luck sheath underwear has two pouches
one for your dick one for your balls it
keeps things separated so you can get on
with your life without having everything
mashed together down there I mean I wear
them all the time I wouldn't be shocked
if I'm wearing them right now let's see
oh yeah same yep look not planned
colored wearing them colorful I don't
think you can say that there we go we
fixed it's uh it's really the best I
wear them all the time I love it uh it's
my
they really are my favorite underwear so
same go to sheath underwear. comom and
use code drunk to get 20% off your first
order plus sheath underwear 100% moneyb
guarantee that sheath underwear. comom
promo code drunk get sheath underwear
support the show support your balls this
guy's the best he's a military uh guy
too he's a veteran he's a big comedy fan
huge comedy and uh I every underwear I
have is like ripped up in the pieces
Swiss cheese this [__] stays good so oh
yeah and they make it for guys and gals
the ladies got it so yeah get some
sheath best undies in the
[Music]
biz are we rolling order he pulled an OJ
he wrote a book damn but OJ got away
with it and then wrote the book that's
true it's funny you see OJ he went
through the trial and wrote the book
right this guy didn't go through a trial
did he no he was squeaky he was off he
was good to go yeah I saw sh Knight was
like I'm not going to testify and like
yeah well your words worth a lot at this
point you know you see when OJ puts on
Instagram every comment is just knife
knife knife knife knife knife knife he's
on camera on show as like a sports
correspondent really it's kind of
hilarious it's hilarious to have just a
show where you have a sports show where
you're like y just make OJ the sports
correspondent yeah that is amazing damn
that's czy is legitimately funny that's
what I keep hearing is he on bar stool
no he's got his own sports show but dude
he there's a clip of him on like a new
show we got to pull it up he literally
dude he gets shot and he's like he's
like yeah people came for me but they
didn't get me like he was talking tough
after like he was out of the hospital
like a day and he's talking [__] wow
it's pretty cool if I got shot I would
that'd be my whole personality I'd just
be like oh [__] I don't want to go
outside again I got shot this is my
whole thing I wouldn't be bragging about
it who I'd be like please don't do that
again that hurts please I love you
whatever want I'll give you money but
the Tupac thing is crazy cuz I heard he
got caught from Tik tocking he was
making Tik Tok videos yeah he was he was
bragging about it on Tik Tok which too
bad JFK never had a Tik Tock guy that'
be great if that existed back then it
would have been a shorter Oliver Stone
film true what do we got is this it I
don't know you paused on a one last
question what uh no this isn't it what
exactly did the did you hear the guy say
trying to like they said it's not it but
you're going to let it roll out great
great Google guy we got Google [__] uh
you're not touching that coffee take it
I'm taking it all
right so you were in Europe for a month
yeah I missed you man I've been talking
a big game hey I'm a tough guy I'm cool
and I was like I don't get jet lagged it
hits you two days later oh man what do
you mean you what are you Superman you
get jet lags I never got it really I I
got to Europe I I I adjusted quick I
land back here I'm wrecked my head feels
like it's this big I'm cloudy I'm gay
I'm all over the place but Europe was a
blast I'm cultured now can you explain
the pictures of all you guys dressed
like gay bath house lot TOS with David
Bowie yeah well we went to the KitKat
Club pull that up I'm sure there's not a
lot of photos of it because they don't
allow phones but no Berlin everyone said
if you're going to Berlin you got to go
to a sex club and I said you damn right
who you talking to uh you know I get
that too in like Montreal you got to go
to a strip club I think I hang out with
[__] scumbags well I was with just
Lane but um so yeah so I was like all
right we got to do it but if you go you
got to dress up you can't just show up
in a [__] cardigan and an Argyle
Sweater so uh the lady was all over at
the wife was like we're going to this
store like the sex club store we're
going to get the boots we're getting the
shorts we're getting the gar belts we're
getting the neck collar that's a
manscaped uh boxer brief by the way I
had no shorts and we spent a fortune on
this [__] uh but all you've already lost
it what are you doing okay pictures
there so we got uh yeah were those
uncomfortable this does not look
comfortable ah you you got of get used
to it I mean I'm wearing fish nets too
if you notice they're pink and uh had a
decent bulge I took a blue chew and yeah
I got eyeliner going it was fun you guys
look like a like a sexy band in the 80s
or something yeah yeah Duran Duran or
something yeah so uh we show up the
thing opens at 10:00 we got there at
like 9:15 cuz like we should get some
food first I didn't know you're supposed
to wear like a trench coat you get in
and then there's lockers so everyone get
why would you know that that's insane
yeah so we're walking around the street
like this an hour before eating schwarma
so I'm at a schwarma place like I'll
have the lamb please and the guy's like
what the [__] and I'm just eating it
they I think they just thought we were
weird
Americans um so we get in there and it
is insane there's a room there's so many
different rooms there's a techno room a
Tango Room there's a full swimming pool
Tango Tango that feels like two classy
of dance for this outfit well people
start tangoing to get some cooking and
then they start uh [__] so we saw is
there sex in there full- on sex [__]
everywhere there's a bunch of bars in
there there's a bunch of uh couches and
nothing is sanitized everything would
get me tooed in like eight minutes here
no because you're volunteering it I
guess so me too is the work environment
thing not the this wasn't this isn't
where Weinstein was doing his deeds I
don't know it felt like it there was a
casting couch it was wild but there's an
old guy jerking off there was a guy yeah
old I'm talking 80 like a Biden just
walking around woo baby maybe it was him
there was a naked guy in a wheelchair he
was uh you know handicapped just going
around full dong out it was crazy in a
wheelchair in a wheelchair it's it's a
beautiful story they were uh dwarves
with with with a collars and and a and a
leash are people wearing masks they
protecting their identity no shut all
out there that's that's where I got coid
no mask you got Co then no I'm just
kidding but uh yeah it was insane and
then eventually after being there
because it just flies by cuz there's so
much stimulus so much to look at and I
go hey wife we got to go bang and she's
like what really I'm like
yeah I'm like well when in Rome
everyone's doing it so we [__] like in
public in public and the fact that I got
hard is a goddamn Miracle at all the
other that's like I mean I want to yes
and you here but you're you're [__]
in public now with the what kind of
person have you become you you you blend
in you know you go to Berlin you you you
know you go with the people Mark's next
slide is we went to a Nazi rally I
didn't want to salute but you got to
blend in I was following
ERS so uh I'm banging the L now here's
where it gets real wacky it wasn't easy
I mean it took a lot of a lot of like
you good is there like a way to get hard
in an environment like this mostly
looking at the other women that helped
cuz it's naked women everywhere he
looked at the guy in the wheelchair he's
like that'll do it oh Lieutenant Dan
over there so I'm plowing the lady and
this I got her from behind this is open
dance floor like that oh my God and uh
this guy comes up and Taps me on the
shoulder and I go uhoh this might we
might be in trouble I don't know if I'm
doing something wrong wrong and I look
back and he goes me next and I go what
the [__] get out of here they don't have
me too in Amsterdam they have me next
yeah hash me next and but that's normal
there he wasn't even being a dick he was
just like oh all right you you met some
lady who wants to get Raad I'll do her
next so that was uh kosher it's I don't
mean to sound you know prude here but
it's so unromantic you know like like
part of the fun is the Chase and the and
the seduction and dude just being like
you line up like it's the bathroom right
it's a little weird isn't it yeah he
took a number uh but like a deli exactly
I'm Number Two start raming
hero he wanted that beef tongue you
asked for a sample
yeah what uh that's incredible you did
that well how many people were watching
uh well it's so normal that like people
walk by and go oh how about that then
they just move on are you worried about
getting recognized a little but the
outfit helped I had a couple people say
hey comedy which is weird I said comedy
and they're yelling your catchphrase W
yeah Mark's [__] his wife I gave a
praise Allah out of the game and so I go
ah get out of here I wave him off and
now I'm starting to get like all right
I'm [__] this woman in public uh I
got a guy ta me on the shoulder there's
people everywhere people are staring at
us there's the [__] in the the
wheelchair with the mask and a dick
clamp and I'm kind of starting to lose
it like all right I got to free I'm
freaking out I got to stop this did you
come no I was about to there's a guy
next to me I looked to my left old guy
jerking off staring at me with his
tongue out and I said that's it wrapped
it up couldn't do it the wife's like
what are you doing I was going I was
getting into it I was like ah that and
she was like oh and I we walked away I
hate to say it but under under the
circumstances he was in the right no I'm
not mad at guy you [__] in public at
a sex club he should get the jerk off to
it if he was a little better looking I
would have gone with it he was an ugly
guy and he was kind of scary was Jo
Biden if it was Hunter you would have
done it yes exactly it could have been
Hunter that's true Hunter gather but
yeah so I I I had to bail and she was
kind of like oh that was a little
anticlimactic and I was like I know but
that the jerk guy I was out the jerk guy
I can only go so far we're still you
know comedians who live in New York I
mean I don't think I could ever do could
you ever do something like that no but I
love how Matt Peters could you yeah how
the peeves have gone from the street if
New York are too crowded to I don't like
this guy jerking off on my wife yeah
Subway I'll take it things have gone too
far yes to se club before Oh you have
how was that it was really weird a lot
of old people yeah yeah I was listening
to a guy [__] my wife in the other
room a guy your wife my ex-wife oh whoa
is that what ended it that 6-year-old
lady asked me if I wanted a b job I said
a 60-year-old lady well she was old dude
you know uh yeah I guess you don't ask
your age but
that's uh God damn Matt you like a whole
another life I guess that's who should
be at the sex club as old people if
you're young and you're starting at that
place that's [__] weird well that's
the thing about this club is they're
very uh picky so everyone in there was
it is either hot people with great
bodies or anomalies you know the
wheelchair guy the the dwarf uh the you
know the guy with the Gip mask and
covered in tattoos like everyone had a
thing or you were hot so the only reason
we got in is cuz we our promoter got us
on the
list thank God what a weird request yeah
I love that you did that that's insane
oh you pulled up the the Boogie
Nights damn what a sad scene woo that
was Peters after the
wife that's a tragic character brutal
there's a lot of sad characters in
Boogie kns but that one takes a cake
yeah sad it's not a good sign when
you're more sad than Seymour Hoffman in
a movie that's it's hard to pull off
when you're the more depressing
character yeah dude Mark I cannot
believe you did this well you know I was
out there so long out in Europe you kind
of detach and you just like who am I
anymore and you kind of just start going
into these weird but how are you going
to go back to just [__] your wife on
your bed at home after doing something
like this well I hired a guy he comes
out he stands by the bed and we're good
to go yeah no but it's actually nice to
be back cuz now I can like be myself and
throw her legs around in there I was
like head on a swivel I was like a Cub
Scout you know so you were there with a
friend did he get to see any of this uh
no I wanted to get away from Doug Doug
key everybody but he uh he had his own
fun he he met some girls he met some
girls and he's a good-looking guy he's
ripped and the guys in there weren't
great the women were gorgeous but the
guys weren't great so he really stood
out and he got hit on quite a bit yeah
he's a good-looking dude good-looking
guy 12pack huge arms and uh yeah they
loved him is there a language barrier
when you're trying to hook up with
someone there it's no the only thing was
the bouncer was a bit of a dick cuz he's
you know he's so important his big Nazi
bald buff guy was like how come we got
to learn English you can't learn German
and we were like H we don't live here
and he's like yeah yeah you damn right
you don't live here and I get in there
and I think that's just part of it like
they're me kind of fun when they are
yeah you go to like a burger place like
uh Paul's Burger Joint and the and the
waitress is just kind of rude to you and
you're like I kind of like it yes that's
where it starts the the minor abuse and
you end up in a sex Club but yeah and I
will say there was something fun about
the no phones like you're like I got to
take a photo of that I got to take then
after 20 minutes you're like [__] it
let's live I like that there's no
phones I this on video this jerk the
phone you break out cuz you're bored
you're not bored at a sex club you know
good point you break your phone out when
you know your girlfriend's telling you a
story not when you're good point [__]
your girlfriend also makes you feel
pretty good about the dong size I'm no
prize here there some losers L some some
real acorns in a bush acorns in a bush
is the worst way that little turtle head
popping you know what I'm talking about
yeah like oh and a guy you know what's
weird the guy jerking off that guy gets
he's got a whole backstory like that
person has a life I know like you know
maybe he's like a widow or something and
he's just like yeah I'm going to I'll be
a jerk off at the club guy now I had the
same thought you go to Subway sandwiches
and that guy's in there he's eating or
or a lady a hot lady just like at the
airport but they don't know about the
secrets yeah he's deep Thro in the sub
but he's still eating there he's got a
12 iner yeah
but yeah there was some impressive dongs
too but uh I felt pretty good yeah at
the end of the day I mean you're [__]
you feel good enough to whip it out and
[__] your wife in there that's true this
episode's going to be demonetized in a
second we literally open with Mark like
I [__] my wife in a club I didn't even
think about that I mean whatever it
happens it's a true story and it was at
a sex club you know I did it in the
right place it was appropriate I I can't
believe it I don't think I don't think I
could perform in public if this was in
the Bronx I couldn't have done it but
the fact you're so far away you know
yeah I think there's another reason you
could have done in the Bronx to be
honest not a lot of acorn there yeah
good point good point but uh no I know
what you mean the the the removal you're
gone so long it's almost like who cares
right exactly there's a weird thing when
you're on the road long enough there's a
party that takes over like who gives
this [__] give me give me other
highlights of Europe okay so uh we got
three days off which was a gift because
you're living out of that suitcase
you're on a flight every day a train
every day it's it's it's one country to
the next to the next and it's a lot on
you so we had 3 days off the wife left
cuz she was like I got to go back to
work I have to go back to civilization
me and Doug go [__] it we got three days
off what should we
do [__] it we got drunk we bought
tickets to Paris we flew to Paris which
was a horrific flight we to connect in
rikic rovic whatever my favorite tennis
player yeah no Vex and uh we had to get
a it was like an 8 Hour travel day we
wanted to to kill ourselves this is why
Doug at least you're with someone though
yes and this is why I love Doug this
[__] bought those boots he
bought like you know 8 in platform
whatever boots to wear to the club he's
like I got the receipt I'm going to
return these boots when I get back to
America a Payless cuz they were $60 he
carried those boots all over Europe oh
my God I couldn't believe it so we go to
Paris he's got the boots with him uh but
we go to Paris and you want to kill
yourself the the [__] flight is Hell
connecting language barrier you're tired
you're hung over you're packing you got
the boots right when you land in Paris
you get in Uber you pass by that Eiffel
Tower you go this is the best decision
we' ever made we got a little Airbnb
Doug's such a nut he set up four shows
we set up four shows at a at a little
club we sell them all out and we had a
great time oh Paris it's so cool that
you're at a point in your career where
you can go to Paris and say I want to
sell out a show in Paris and people come
out that's how I felt like it's not the
same but like I had a canc flight in
Montreal and I was stuck for the night
pop-up show that night sells out and
you're like it's amazing we're at a
point in our lives where you know we can
just do that it's I'm grateful totally
agree that's so so give me some Paris
highlights I mean Paris it's a reason
why it's cliche like the prettiest City
cuz it really is I mean there's a lady
singing opera on the bridge and the sun
was setting I'm holding a prco at a
restaurant just looking at everything
the boats go by the Eiffel Tower Doug
key we went to uh um sakre Sacred Heart
Church he cried he wept it was so pretty
was like I was supposed to come here
with my grandmother and she died I'm
like holding Doug we look like two
weirdos I'm eating a baguette he is a
baguette I feel like you're doing the
the weird part of the relationship with
him yeah you're [__] your girlfriend
in the sex club then you're like they're
there to him in Parish what the hell
that's true that's true hell happened
here then I [__] Doug he [__] him in
the church yeah same old guy was jerking
off in the church oh yeah yeah Notre
damn so uh we had a great time did the
shows the shows were great and uh then
we flew back and just did Dublin Dublin
was the hottest crowd that vicer street
is an amazing venue if you ever get a
chance to do it in Dublin yeah it's up
there with like the Wilbur or the Moore
it's just magical I'm filming my next
special at the Wilbur in March tickets
on sale later this month but yeah I'm
I'm pumped man I feel good about the
hour it's it's cooking so my friend saw
in Chicago was like holy [__] I was
blowing away all right that was a hot
night cuz we had Matteo Lane plays the
Chicago theater Chicago Kid big deal you
know and then uh we we're on the same
flight it's his husband him me and we uh
literally I go up to him with the urinal
I just see a mohawk and I realized I
take a chance cuz I was just like hey
you [__] and then I was like oh [__]
this might not be Matteo but then I was
like thank God I just chaned on the
Mohawk wait he a mohawk yeah oh I didn't
even know that kind sex club story
yeah yeah then I started [__] him in
the bathroom and I
jerk so we're sitting on the you know on
the flight we're going there and he goes
hey I'm making pizza at at lumati later
tonight in the kitchen for my YouTube
channel you want to do with me I was
like of course so I you know I do we
make pizza it's so [__] fun but you
know that deep dish pizza is no joke oh
yeah so you know I had three slices I'm
dying I feel sick and then my girlfriend
sees me post about it she's like oh I
wanted Chicago Pizza I was like [__] it
ordering it again I had for dinner as
well I wanted to kill myself I worked
out twice the next day we go to a yoga
class I did I swam like 60 laps in the
hotel we were in a hotel with this sick
pool uh but we do uh yoga the next day I
just was like I need something to do she
set it up so we go it's called Uh funky
Friday it was the worst thing I've ever
done in my life it was a hot class we're
in the dark we were the only people that
like I guess there was like they're all
regulars so they had like inside jokes
that we didn't get they're just like are
you guys ready for funk fun Friday and
I'm just like I know everyone's laughing
I'm like I don't get how this is funny
is this like fun mom stuff is that what
this is I guess but they keep making
jokes like that and they're like it's
funky cuz the room is set up different
and I'm like okay I have no basis for
comparison cuz I've never been here I
don't get the joke anything funky is
never fun it's never fun and she kept
saying it oh that's weird it's like
those places where you drink and paint
whoa everybody watch out we're drinking
wine and painting woo crazy so lame it's
like drinking on a podcast just to make
it stand out it's like pathetic losers
um but yeah Chicago Theater he does it
Friday I do it Saturday so we do guest
sets on each other shows and I was like
what a [__] crazy weekend that we
just can do that that's incredible and
uh yeah both both sold out it was like
you know his crowd was amazing my crowd
was amazing uh he got a nice little
Chicago pop when he came out for my
audience which was nice Hometown kid and
uh yeah his whole family's there it was
pretty cool and uh yeah it was a hell of
a night man Chicago is just the best
it's the best that's why I did the
special there too something about it
yeah exactly I love it I even mentioned
James web on stage he's a Chicago kid
every one applauded for cuz he's filming
yeah cuz he's I bet he brought I think
he brought a lot of friends you know oh
and that's a great theater that theater
is special that Marquee you can't beat
it dude I was doing crowd work in a
close to 4,000 Cedar cuz it's that
intimate for a 4,000 se you know 3600 or
something so you know I only did it for
like you know seven minutes or so you
know toward the end just to uh just to
[__] around a little bit but uh you can
do it in a the that's how crazy it is
yeah beautiful play I think melany did a
special there as well yeah I feel like
he picks really classy theaters always
cuz didn't he do one at uh he did one at
Radio City I think he did one at Town
Hall too oh maybe he always picks like
really classy beautiful theaters yeah
wow that is so cool though I I love
Chicago I can't believe Mato got hair
plugs and then does a mohawk is that a
weird moovie cocky yeah who do you think
you are well we uh Our Guest today Nick
offerman's a Illinois guy so he messaged
me he's like the Chicago Theater you
know so I'm excited he's coming on today
man he's a great guy where did you meet
him I met him in Calgary so uh I
actually met him years ago to benefit in
Austin he was hosting um and it was like
me him uh a bunch of a bunch of big
comedians were on it I was like the
smallest comic on it but he hosted and
he was really cool and then uh we did
this gig The Great Outdoors Fest in
Calgary with me him and Dan soda [__]
amazing hang hot show so fun so does he
do does he have jokes like does he do an
act he does a lot of musical stuff some
stories yeah I mean he's super funny
obviously you've seen him you know and
he's an incredible comedic and dramatic
actor I can't wait to meet him I've told
the story before but the only time I met
him was a Conan and he was in a robe and
he jerked off no he uh he was in a oh I
was in a robe and I was getting a
haircut and he said shave the boy and
bring him to my room that was that was
the only exchange we had laugh it killed
in the room and that was it yeah I saw
him on TV this morning he was on Morning
Joe promoting his new book so uh pumped
to have him here is it just a I should
know this is it a biography is it a no
it's a it's a travel book oh great uh so
yeah why don't we pull that graphic up
so we're prepared yes yes s pulls up
mind comp got to get it together
Sally why don't we uh yeah there we go
why don't we we want to just chill till
he gets here we got s minutes I'm got to
pee anyway all right you going to pee
should we get ice for the scotch too we
have it
there oh hey I didn't see you there just
want to let you know that I'm performing
at the Madison Square Garden theater
November 4th and I can't wait ticket on
my website we got it okay what do I do
about the burning
sensation what do I
do hey hey folks we might be drunk It's
brought to you by ship station it's the
Calm before the holiday storm before
things get too nutty make sure you're
prepared with ship station ship station
lets you simplify and automate your
shipping no matter how big your business
grows automate your shipping and even
returns in their easy to navigate
dashboard with a free trial and quick
setup it's easy to find out if ship
station is right for the next step in
your business wo we love ship station
and you got to get on it because uh
things are about to get even crazier
it's fun giving gifts it's fun sending
stuff so get the hell in there easily
manage orders print labels compare rates
and automate delivery notifications
you'll even get discounts so up to 84%
off ups and up
USPS rates whether you sell on Amazon
Etsy eBay or Shopify ship station will
work for you join the 130
130,000 companies who've grown their
business with ship station 98% of
companies who use ship station for a
year become lifelong customers we should
use this for Merch set your business up
for holiday season success with
shipstation go to shipstation.com and
use code drunk today D R and K and sign
up for your free 60-day trial holy hell
at shipstation.com COD drunk get on it
two girls one cup had a soundtrack I
guess so uh you got a new book out we
should say out of the gate oh yeah right
here Nick Offerman with the deer and
Antelope
play thanks for joining us man this is a
travelog book it is yeah do you do the
um audio book I do I love to do audio
books uh even even more thank you than
writing the book I think thank you Matt
totally it's like a really long
podcast
Cheetos is is this your second book it's
my fifth book your fifth book okay fifth
book that's a lot Jesus that's crazy
well you
Grisham jeez yeah it's I I never
expected to be a touring
humorist I just wanted to get good parts
and plays in
Chicago and I had a scenery shop I built
scenery for
plays and then like I got cast in a
couple movies and a couple people said
uh you should come to La you make funny
faces so I did and um and here we are uh
so I started touring
performing as a humorist and Rashida
Jones came to one of my early shows and
said I love your your talk with like an
agenda it sounds like you're reading
from your book and I thought oh actually
I have some more stories of Jack assery
yeah so then I cast about to see if I
could get a book deal and I did what
what do a humorist
entail
well it's interesting CU i' I've been
devouring both of your work I'm um um
I've been fans of yours before like I
met Sam doing a gig together recently
but uh you both had just caught my eye
over the years because I described you
to my wife as like the grandchildren of
Carlin oh man Jes chist and and what I
mean by that is you're not super you're
not very
attractive what I mean by that is you
can tell you spend a a lot of blood and
sweat and tears is like [__] with
language and [__] with the line of
like what's what's funny what can I get
away with there's intelligence because
in watching in listening to episodes of
this podcast uh people kept talking
about Dave tell and I've always heard
his name and I texted Sam and said I
literally have never I've only heard his
name for years and years I've I've never
seen him uh and so he's told me to check
out his album skanks For The Memories
yes and I and I listened to it in a
hotel room the other day and it was I
mean it's it's so uh he's so aggressive
his energy is so aggressive that you
like you you either turn it off or you
turn it up and I turn I turned it up
where it's just like he's not going to
[__] let give you let you C your
catch your breath right and he got me
laughing and of course there's stuff
it's 20 years old so there's stuff
that's like oh yeah can't do that one
anymore but but uh but in the same in
the same vernacular you can tell that
you're not just like you know telling
dick jokes you're playing with the form
in a way uh that that uh when I decided
to start doing this I was aware that I
don't have the kind of brain that writes
jokes I knew I think Zach galanakis is
one of the comedians I've known the
longest and he was just always aware of
how he can sit there and just take any
Bal situation and think of the funniest
goddamn way to describe it or just the
stupidest non Seer that you're like [__]
man like Mitch Hedberg isms that I'm I'm
like God damn it look what you just did
with a bag of Doritos or whatever right
yeah Galvan AIS has great on liners that
people don't talk about because he's
such a big actor with the hangover and
whatnot but killer yeah we watched his
like I remember his like half hour on
Comedy Central being like this is
[__] great I love this he's he's
somewhere like he's got a little Steven
right to him as well out of left field
but so when I started doing this I I was
like okay I don't write jokes but people
laugh at the slow way in which I talk
and so I just decided to start calling
myself a humorist and I I wrote out like
a 90-minute show and I do songs and I
just felt like it allows me because when
uh initially Netflix had my first
special on Netflix it was called
American ham oh yeah they since pulled
it off uh but um but people would
complain people would go through all the
comedy and they'd get to me and they'd
be like this isn't [__] com this
isn't a comedian right and I was like I
I don't really disagree with you like
you read the comments are you nuts no I
don't uh I don't remember where I came
across that cuz I I didn't know you
could have comments on like a on that
streamer um oh we did YouTube special so
I I saw them all but I'm like you know I
don't I don't dwell on them but I'd be
like oh okay I I I read the comment I I
read reviews of my books and people
really love my books uh like probably
you guys 93% of people are know know
what they're in for and they love it and
7% somehow thought you were a Christian
or
like they're like Nick off if you have
ever been to church Nick Offerman thinks
you're an idiot oh
like no I was drunk when I wrote that
well I mean I wouldn't say idiot no I
when whenever I talk about religion at
all I go into all caps mode and
literally
say every each to each their own like I
could I absolutely have no judgment
about any of this but if you're going to
try and make kids pray in school like if
you're going to do shitty things in the
name of religion that's what I want to
talk about which is the most shitty
things have been done yeah in history
but also extremists it's okay to have an
opinion on extremists that's another
thing it's like if you have an opinion
on anything like Brian rean has bits
that offend people I know but I just did
a Dublin and we did a little Q&A after
one guy was like talk about the the
Catholics and the Protestants there are
just crazy divided it's like they hate
each other still and I I was like guys
relax both of them aren't real that was
the punchline and I posted the clip you
know fun times comedian humorist and I
got a million like you're going to hell
screw you and these are all the the Free
Speech guys like I can't do a religion
bit but yeah yeah it is it's it's a it's
a very uh tough time who by the way we
have I haven't been introduced to our
friend here this is Winnie Winnie's
trying to get more food this is my
girlfriend's dog and she goes to work
and I was like I I feel bad leaving the
dog at home yeah when when he deserves
to be here and to weigh in on matters of
religion oh yeah she hates the
Jews she only knows one it's not fault
you know I have one Jewish friend and he
forgets to let her out
sometimes he uh he can't eat American
ham so uh yeah you're uh you're doing
like the Press tour now I saw you on
MSNBC this morning I just flipped it on
I was like oh [__] there he is fun that
it was actually nerve-racking um I am
doing uh the it's the paperback
publication of of this book this I'm
very proud of my book but I also just
recently did a PSA and this is the least
sexy thing that will ever happen on your
podcast um I don't know he farted on
Allison Brie that was pretty bad oh man
yeah I got
hard she loves it
uh I um I am invested in uh agrarian
farming and so I made this PSA for uh
with the nrdc the natural resources
defense Council it's this lobbying group
um uh purporting like in favor of soil
Health like encouraging we're lobbying
Congress to encourage Farmers to plant
cover crops it's it's a great climate
change fighter it's a great agriculture
thing and it's something that I will
always be invested in there's a lot of
it in my book although the book is also
very entertaining uh all right there is
soil talk though full disclosure but so
the MSNBC appearance was not funny uh
the PSA is funny you got a line or two
in there I played dirt yeah but they're
asking me and it's like you know people
always you know people always [__] on me
basically I'm dirt um but we should take
care of our dirt and you know you can
imagine it needs it's Health it's
microorganisms and it actually makes it
uh it's a great carbon sink if you have
healthy dirt it it saves water it does
all these things and so it's
nerve-wracking to go on
MSNBC not and not be there as an
Entertainer where they're like so tell
us you know tell us about [__]
farming and Congress and and fortunately
there was a really smart lady named
arohi from the
nrdc and I could I could sort of set her
up where I'm like well 11% of our
nation's emissions come from
Agriculture and and then she would kick
in with a a paragraph of intelligence
yes classic
humorist that's right the old Garrison
Keeler throw it throw her Riders in the
Sky it's got to excite the TV people and
they're like oh this guy's got some dirt
on people and then you get there and
you're like no literally soil this is it
you grab a napkin to mat also could you
I mean I want to I want to try some of
Nick's uh Scotch too Nick Offerman has
his own brand of log ofen how the hell
did you pull that you you have a deal
with I would say the best scotch yeah
it's up there for sure thank you thank
you
Sally can you imagine it's
insane I when I was
29 uh so two years ago when I was 29 in
1999 I was at a film festival in
Chicago and my
filmmaker uh Scott King bless his name
uh he's in Europe now he said you know
we introd produ the film and we'll we'll
be back in 90 minutes for a
Q&A and he taught me the first lesson of
of film festivals which is then you go
have a drink it's the perfect amount of
time so we go to a bar and he
says up to that point I was a broke
theater actor so I would have pints and
pints of beer and then on a special
occasion we'd get jamus in and and pound
some some Irish whiskey which is not
even the best whiskey that's funny that
J great though it's solid I love Jamon
but when J was your your number one it
ain't happy sure sure but I mean I I
wouldn't have known like it was all
about what do you have what's the best
affordable whis that you have at the
Chicago Theater Pub is it cool if we
drink yours and you have ours oh sure
cuz Mark and I have own Rye it's Bodega
cat Ry oh yeah we're in the same Biz I
did not know that but I'm I'm a big Rye
fan hell yeah same um so so he he bought
me my he said let me do you want to try
some Scotch I said sure I've heard of
Eugene O'Neal wrote about it like let me
check it out and he got me a glass of
loga vulin and so he didn't say anything
else so it was like this is scotch and
then I was ruined yes it's amazing thank
you very much but then how do they how
do you get in cahoots with them there's
a lot of things I like that uh no one's
putting my face
on Cheers by the way guys and thanks
again for coming
cheers to Lucky sons of [__] hell
yeah get the
book that is so
good your Ry is quite nice thank as well
thank
you top notch like of it's so smoky it's
like it's like drinking bacon or
something it's like a a campfire in your
mouth yeah so I was 29 so then that
became my drink and then I you know I
learned and I'm I'm not picky uh if we
have whiskey we're we're in good shape
uh I'm not persnikity sure but over the
years if if pit places had L oful and
that's what I would order and naturally
I learned to then have a rival a rivalry
with Lefroy oh yeah um and they're
actually their Nextdoor Neighbors on the
coast of of Isa Lefroy lulan and EG are
right next to each other and they're all
I like EG too yeah they're all nice
winter Scotch totally
yeah so when I was then 38 I got the job
of Ron Swanson on Parks and wreck sure
and somewhere early on it was in the
script Ron Leslie comes in for a meeting
Amy polar and Ron pulls out two glasses
and a bottle of Scotch so we get to
there to the day and I open my drawer
it's lulan 16 and I thought this these
prop people are so good that they found
out my favorite Scotch that's amazing
and it was like a year later
I went to Mike Sher who create was the
main creator of the show I went to his
birthday party and I was talking to him
and Adam Scott walked up and gave him a
bottle of log ofan 16 and said happy
birthday and I said you know that's on
the show cuz that's my favorite scotch
and Mike said no you [__] idiot it's
my favorite
Scotch did you think they read your mind
or something and so so thanks to Mike
who also had Exquisite taste uh it
became Ron scotch and we used it
frequently on the show and eventually we
said has anybody heard from login we
literally have given them like a $2
million worth of screen time yes and we
we we made a big deal out of it on the
show and finally towards the end the
answer was no we hadn't heard from them
that's crazy they never reached out like
this is so cool they were pretty small
obscure show so I think it hadn't quite
and American shows take a couple few
years that's true to get over and
infiltrate the UK and and Ireland um and
so uh towards the end Chris Pratt got
cast in Guardians of the Galaxy and that
was going to shoot in London and so if
we wanted to still have him on the
season of parks they had to come up with
a way to go shoot in London our little
Indiana show yeah so our brilliant
producer named Mor Morgan sacket who
shoots all the log ofan commercials by
the way um came up with with this way to
take the show uh to to London and they
sent my character to the log ofan
distiller and so it I mean it just was
was ridiculous and so we all hit it off
they liked me and they said maybe what
if we start doing commercials and I said
oh yes that would be fine just inching
your way in you want to pay me to say
that I Like Oxygen sure right I'll
[__] back oxygen
um and so I started doing these
commercials uh you can find them on
YouTube we have a channel called my
talesof whiskey.com pull it up there are
I think 50 of them by now and they're
mostly stupid comedy shorts uh is there
is there like a favorite of yours we
could pull up um gosh well the the the
one that has a gazillion hits was this
like uh this one-off
idea a writer from uh 99 named David
Phillips came up with just pitching you
know [__] and it was to replace the
U log you know how there used to be uh
the uog channel at Christmas you put it
on the TV and it's just a burning
fireplace so we did our version of that
where it's a fireplace and me and a
chair next to it and somebody turned it
into a 10-hour
Loop and like every 15 minutes I take a
sip that's the uog wow and it it h it
has you know it's a so there's no words
no that's amazing all I do is sit there
and so it looks cool as hell though
that's brilliant at Christmas then
people like in bars or workplaces will
put they'll just put it on as like
wallpaper so that was our biggest hit
that's like some sort of War hole type
art piece at a party yeah in and of
course it was just a prank on it was
like a a throwaway idea and the at the
time the longest media we had we could
do a 45 minute take on the card
that we had and so the director is like
crawling
or I mean how bad you you must be
farting you got to pee I mean how long
you do this I mean that's my bag it was
a 45 minute take wow I love it it's like
kind of Zen it is I mean and then we did
we did one for New Year's Eve out in
front of the Distillery so so we start
doing these commercials and uh it's
Morgan sacket and uh Dean Holland a
great TV director who directed the most
episodes of parks and wreck mhm
uh we often go back been to the
Distillery six or seven times in the
last 10 years and then eventually they
decided to make a log
ofan Offerman version finally which is
so it just it keeps I mean I guess
they're going to offer me the company at
some eventually it continues to escalate
well the first time we saw it I was like
oh like Nick Offman and then Matt was
like no seriously I was like oh I didn't
know yeah it's it's crazy uh I'm very
grateful um it's it's a it's a
apparently you know the the show and my
uh my endorsement has done them a lot of
good okay and so we're very grateful for
the relationship like every time they
pick us up for another year we we
were're just like okay great yes yeah
we're trying to get Sam one with Pepto
all right we got to get your face on a
Pepto cuz he drinks it all the time with
the hangovers and the I mean upset
stomach on the road I've switched to
Pepper pills but like you know you're
doing a gig on the road you chug a Pepto
yeah I'm trying to get into Plan B I
want my face on the pill that'll
definitely make women want to take it
for sure uh I'm inside of them so yeah
this is an amazing gig so what kind of
input did you have in the making of the
Offerman Scotch the there's a a
brilliant guy named steuart Morrison who
uh and now uh it used to be an obscure
independent Distillery uh they have
since been purchased by diio which is a
big beverage company so I've through
diio I've also done commercials for
talisker and Oben um but but mainly uh
lul talisker's pretty great I mean
they're both great they're fantastic I
mean insane the uh if if it ain't broke
don't fix it but this this great uh
Alchemist named Stuart Morrison is he
he's the guy in the laboratory and it's
pretty fascinating um because they have
think about it like for this is 11 years
so they have in order to come up with
like 50,000 cases of this they have to
find that much liquid available and then
the one that we're doing right now uh or
this one for example uh we we finished
it in these charred Oak casks so he he
does these experiments where we do
tastings and they're very generous like
they let me he sends me a kit and and we
we do mix We he's like try a drop of
this and you know taste now taste this
one taste that one and so ultimately
he's the chef he knows what the [__]
he's doing and I'm The Sorcerer's
Apprentice where I'm at his elbow and I
ultimately get to say which one is yummy
right and then and then he's like thanks
to Nick offerman's expert palet and they
try to they try to Goose it up as though
I know what the [__] I'm doing which all
I'm doing is saying I like number seven
b
um and and so I love it I mean I also
write all the copy on the back of the
box and like you know I pitch sort of
jokes there's little illustrations of me
and stuff um so I'm I'm very active in
it because I whether it's my books or
anything that I endorse I don't you know
I I don't put my name on something if if
I don't stand behind it and I try to be
as involved as possible just so because
I think it's douchy to just yeah if if
if if it was just my name I don't think
anybody would pay me for that right
right well you did uh also in parks and
R isn't your character it's Elmo's
Steakhouse right um St Elmo St Elmo in
Indianapolis yeah was that you or is
that the like the character is
gonna is that a thing that you brought
in or did they just say like oh he's
going to like this Steakhouse oh well I
mean they you know great TV writers what
the their Alchemy is they take aspects
of your personality and distill them in
a way where that you know whether it's
Aziz or Aubrey Plaza or Amy or me when
they were creating the show I was in my
wood shop I actually have a wood shop in
La and I kept talking to them on the
phone we're create like before we ever
started and I would have to turn off the
table saw or whatever the dust
collection and and eventually they're
like wait are you what is this and said
it's I have a wood shop I I build
heirloom furniture and boats and [__]
and they said can we come over there and
they got on a bus and all the writers
came to my shop and they said this is
hilarious like can we make your
character a woodworker and I was said
yeah great I love it uh so so on the
show Ron's shop is my shop and my and so
somehow my love of meat uh there are
certain aspect ects of me that they then
like crank up to a Superhero level right
so in the in my touring show I do a song
called I'm not Ron Swanson and there's a
line that's like uh he can eat a big ass
steak for every single meal because his
colon is fictitious but mine is all too
real and his Scotch intake would be my
liver's Doom right because mine is
controlled by nature and his by the
whims of the writer's room um humors so
that's a humorous but you did have a you
had a couple drinks with us and he had a
500 a.m. pickup the next day and he
still had a couple drinks with us before
he left I was like that's a [__]
that's a that's not a humorist that's a
comedian right there hell yeah my
bonafides oh wait I had a question [__]
oh I lost it what were you talking
about Ron Swanson steak oh got it back
thank you
now be honest my wife watches the show a
lot she loves the show she puts it on
all the time she's wildly attracted to
you that character she's like he's so
manly he's so masculine you must get
dozens and dozens of letters that's a
that's an interesting question uh and
I'm that I'm suddenly resentful um
because I I feel like I should oh be
getting a a lot of mail um come on
you're a good-look guy great hairline
I'm grateful thank you thanks to your
your bride um I uh she's here by the way
she wants to K my
um I think because I I used to get a lot
of fan mail early on and I used to on
Sundays I would I used to really enjoy
answering my fan mail and that was about
uh
20091 and then one of the reasons parks
and wreck I think hit because we almost
got cancelled every year we were never a
hit show right um in later years once
streamers showed up then it became
wildly popular with young people and
they don't understand that we almost got
cancelled all the time we barely I feel
like it's the same with 30 Rock the
office all these classic com it's not
true though uh the office was a hit was
a ratings hit but it blew up on another
level though on Netflix for sure yeah
absolutely that's also true I mean in
this weird new advent of like Comfort
shows because For the First Time even
post cable you could just have your show
available just watch it over and over um
but so somewhere towards the beginning
suddenly when parks and W did uh take
off to the extent that it did I was
suddenly hugely unable to return fan
mail like it yeah it exploded and and in
order to like just maintain any personal
time I also had to not really engage on
social media and so wherever that would
exist if if any anyone is soliciting my
sexual favors uh I'm I'm unaware I'm
really unaware of it like wow it's out
there I'm glad I'm frankly glad to I'm
grateful to hear because you know my
wife and I have a great thing and and we
still maintain a healthy amount of heat
between us and so I'm also grateful that
it hadn't occurred to me but I was like
where are the I do hear on occasion from
the sort of bear uh Community bet
um depending on what what facial hair
I'm rocking right right well you're an
alpha well I appreciate that uh you're a
top I mean in that world Yeah by by and
large I suppose are the Bears always the
top I didn't even know that I assume
they're the bigger but I don't know what
the bears go at it from time to time
yeah I'm not sure yeah I think I think
you can be a pitcher or catcher as a
bear and I'm relatively ignorant but I
do know there are bears and there are
Cubs yeah because I've met Cubs uh and
generally I you know I hate to make a
stereotype but Cubs are probably more
likely to be found on the bottom of I
would think so any Arrangement
especially in the in baseball they're on
the bottom of the division well boy
that's they're they're my team oh it's
just a bunch of Burke chers and I wish I
wish I could argue with you well I've
been called an otter what is that that's
like a scruffy skinny guy I'm not a
twink
level that's too small I'm like a otter
and then I think you're a giraffe I
would assume are we allowed to say twink
because I remember doing on at I did
that show at midnight back in the day
and Jesse Joyce was like helping with my
punch up of the jokes and I said twink
and he goes you can't say that and I was
like this guy wrote roast jokes for Greg
Geraldo he's told me I can't say this
you know I didn't know that was I don't
know huh I don't know I I didn't know
that either I mean I thought it was I
don't know maybe not it's a cute word
Twi I I yeah yeah man I I suppose in
some circles it could be considered
derogatory Circle that's not how we mean
it though but yeah I I thought it was
just a category of like a puckish or
Fairy like yeah fairy
he's with an e f a e r i e yes like stat
like the we folk got it got it like a
nymph that's right not to make too
obvious a segue here but the the gay
character you played on Last of Us is
Inc that's an incredible episode of
great Arc thank you that was like it it
was a slow burn and great
segue killer killer but I mean I was
watching that and I was just like the
the way it was like a short it was like
a film it wasn't like an episode of TV
it was the I mean and you know hats off
to Neil dman who created the video game
uh but Craig Mason who who did the show
Chernobyl and also uh Craig Mason who
also wrote hangover too like he what is
that right he has the most incredible
Arc at the time what range son was on a
little league team that my wood shop
sponsored so one of my little league
dads and he wrote movies uh like called
superhero movie uh at least a couple of
the scary movies oh wow so he's this
great big which ones did he write can
you look it up so he knows comedy he's
this great big brain that like writes
creates these satires of a form and then
one of my little league dads wrote
hangover to and I was like holy [__]
what it's so incredible cut to he had
the idea for Chernobyl and nobody would
make it of course cuz they're like what
you're going from Hangover to this and
so he he kind of had to make it on his
own he had to produce it himself and of
course it won every award and is an
astonishing I got to watch it everyone's
told me to watch it I got to I got to
put that on it's
incredible we we it it stopped us up in
the beginning of the pandemic when it
came on because it's [__] Chernobyl
like it's nothing is more Bleak it's a
true depiction and like people melting
from radiation and [__] so we shut it
off for a year and a half and then came
back to it and it's it's worth it it's
that actor from Madmen right it's a
Jared Harris yeah that guy's incredible
son of Richard Harris yeah oh I didn't
know that that guy could put him back
Richard Harris he was like a legendary D
yeah they would I mean those guys and
and Peter otou and and uh um what's his
name I believe it was a sir now probably
yeah they would uh uh Oliver Reed they
would do Shakespeare on the west end and
an intermission they'd go across the
alley to the pub and the stage manager
would have to go pull them back on stage
for their entrance and they you know
generally they would come out and
successfully elocute Shakespearean mon
you know they would destroy the audience
just totally shitfaced there's these old
Hollywood stories of Spencer Tracy being
such a blackout drunk that the studio
would hire people to Shadow him and have
to like carry him into a car so there
would be an article and you're like holy
[__] not not stop drinking it's like oh
no we'll help you we'll help you get
this drunk shepher that's great it's a
crazy thing um Craig Mason uh wrote that
episode and and and so I mean that uh
and I I guess I guess I'll tell well no
I'm not going this wasn't in the video
game I assume there wasn't a weird
random gay C it's touched upon oh it is
yeah um and and most people Breeze by
like you had to really dig in deep to
understand uh that they had a
relationship
so this here are some minor spoilers for
The Last of Us video game please uh
which I've never seen Beyond seeing like
stills of the
character uh you meet my character and
he's angry and he has these interactions
with the
leads Frank you is I think you meet I
think he's he's hung himself mhm and so
you understand that they had a
relationship and you see Frank's writes
a letter
about uh there's something about a
partnership like it's it's intimated and
then also in Bill's bunker you find gay
porn magazines I think so there are
Clues and Frank talks about their part
being
Partners but the letter that you find
it's really well done on on Neil's part
it's angry it's it's like [__] I always
[__] hated you like I'm killing my
this is my suicide note and I hated you
but but if you if you get all the clues
you're like oh you you were lovers like
yeah this is this is a marriage we got
to hand it to we've come a long way
since
Frogger depth and relationships and
hidden hidden meanings yeah this is this
has all the Nuance of video games make
more money than movies now right it's
pretty crazy I I gave um me personally
in the late '90s I played a couple games
and lost a couple weeks to them oh yeah
I had did Banjo Kazooie and Earthworm
Jim oh I loved Earthworm Jim and it was
the same guy this is all about Scott
King the guy who gave me my first log
ofin was the first couch I surfed when I
got to LA and he's a wonderful brilliant
uh uh Brainiac we made a a really weird
movie called treasure Island that I'm
really proud of it was Sundance in '98
MH I was couch surfing with him he was a
gamer and he was like hey I just got
these two new games do you want to
basically eat pizza all day for two
weeks and play video games and I was
like yeah yeah man Hollywood is awesome
yeah so we did and we we methodically
beat each of the two games wow and then
at the end of those two weeks I might as
well have been masturbating for 2 weeks
cuz I was like that was amazing and as
soon as it's over I was like like what
the [__] did
I I just lost two weeks of my life this
is Prem Megan Mal it is pre okay I can
almost hear a vagina drying up youm
gyming all day everywhere no I met her
but a year or two later and and my life
got very
happy and I've never needed another
PlayStation yeah you talk about like it
was a heroin phase I did that for a
while and I got out of it then I met my
wife I'm very grateful yeah I've had
those lessons in life where I've had the
opportunity to try something without
getting arrested or or killed and enough
to say oh I I get it I get why people
throw their lives away on narcotics or
video games or whatever it is and for me
uh I have an addictive personality so
I'm thankfully able to say all right
that's enough of that yeah I we were
talking before you got here Matt and I
about uh the episode you did of Last of
Us and it's like first off I think it's
cool as hell That You Don't See a lot of
like badass gay characters on screen
like your character is like a
survivalist badass got a gun got a
camera set up but then we were talking
like was he gay or was he know he was
gay did he know he was gay or does he
show up and he's like I'm lonely cuz I
was thinking about it I was watching
with my girlfriend this episode and I
was kind of like I don't know if I would
be gay in in this type of environment
then by the end of the episode I like oh
I would definitely have been gay right
cuz it was like a meaningful
relationship and that's the only type of
relationship you could have
well I mean to to sort of answer uh your
intimated question I I think he was I
think yes uh he knew he was gay but he
was powerfully closeted yeah you know
when the world still existed that was
part of his bitterness was like he was
going to be goddamned if he was going to
be gay because he didn't he didn't fit
The Stereotype like cuz he was also this
badass MH and that's how I felt so lucky
to get the job because they needed a guy
who could use a shovel and there's
there's only three of us in
Holly Harrison Ford passed and Jane
Lynch was not
available and that's one of the two
jokes that I've written I've written two
jokes that's great joke since I became a
humorist H lesbian jokes they always
work was pretty happy but I said it to
Matteo lame my friend was a gay guy the
other day I was like you know gay guys
make neighborhood
nicer and I said but do lesbians he goes
they build
them yeah that's
great yeah they're they're not they're
not as as visible in the parade because
they're they're fixing the
[Laughter]
floats but yeah that's it's so cool that
you've done these like is it is it okay
to to perpetuate positive stereotypes
like lesbians are great with tools I
don't see why black guys big dicks
Asians are smart that's right that's
exactly what so no well that the Jewish
one is always so weird like Jews are
successful the pieces of [__] I'm like
that's your Zing I know but there also a
lot of the conspiracy theories end with
juy babies there's a lot of bad ones
long enough that's why you don't see a
lot of Jewish conspiracy theorists cuz
we see where they end up they don't
babies aren't kosher you know how could
that work lesbians are heroic unless
they're Rothchilds
yeah is the headline do you so it's so
cool you've been in these movies that
are like first you've been so many funny
movies and funny parts but then like are
you kind of more hungry for these
dramatic roles now um it's a good
question I like I said earlier I I
wanted to get good parts and plays in
Chicago Theater I went to theater school
at the University of
Illinois um which is kind of funny at
champagne Urbana in the middle of the
cornfields but it's actually a great
theater school that prepares you that
teaches you how to stand and perform
Czech off um
but uh and and so in Chicago Theater I I
had a theater company with my friends
called the defiant theater and uh you
kind of do whatever is in your toolbox
whatever is on the season and so I love
doing comedy but I also love being a
scary [__] like the only time I
really won a good award for acting was
in a play in
1995 called the Kentucky cycle um and uh
that's me in the Kentucky
cycle I wore a suit and I was very tired
uh I um it it was a 7h hour play it was
this Pulitzer prizewinning play by uh
Robert
shenin and I played an Irish indentured
servant who was a murderer and it was a
scary [__] that you love to hate
uhuh and so that I thought was my bag I
thought I was like Allan Rickman and in
Robin Hood where I was like or or Die
Hard like yeah
um and I thought that was my Niche um
but then I also love making people laugh
and so I don't really uh my my ambitions
don't lie in genre I have been lucky
enough to just kind of be open to uh I
read what comes in and like after parks
and wreck I never dreamed that I would
get that I would have such a effective
comedy character and it took the genius
of Mike Sher and his writer room and and
and Greg Daniels um and all all these
and Dan Gore who create created book
Brooklyn 99 like they thought of what to
do with this yeah in so much more of a
clever way than I ever could have come
up with and so then after 125 episodes
of that then I got these great offers
from Hot Shots with TV deals that were
like and I was like okay the one thing I
don't want to do obviously is another
Ron Swanson and they're like yes of
course
uh us either so we have this guy he's
like an ex-marine he's great at grilling
you know and they so I got like three
offers of huge jobs that were just
another you know he's he's known for his
mustache or whatever sure and I and I
was like thank you so much but that's
like too similar I yeah I think I'm not
thin uh my my ambitions aren't shallow
enough I could just make a ton of money
playing a guy with a mustache for the
rest of my life yeah then you're the one
note guy yeah yeah but isn't a hard line
to walk between between being the one
note guy and also like well this is what
people want I mean I feel I feel like
you can look at a lot of Jim carre's
movie movies in the 90s and he's kind of
doing a similar character or Bill Murray
or or Will Farrell even who are all
great I agree and it's and and that's
the thing is like and we all have our
our you know our certain tool boxes like
I when I went to theater school I
aspired to be more of like a Gary Oldman
or Daniel D Lewis where you become a
little more
unrecognizable and I think I I Walk the
Line Between because generally it's hard
to disguise my voice people generally
although in The Lego Movie uh I play
MetalBeard the pirate oh yeah and I
sound like a weird Irish pirate and
that's the one time that somebody let me
do something that doesn't sound like
this [__] guy it's weird cuz they
want Nick Offerman for the voice and
then you you come in with that voice are
they annoyed no it was really fun it was
a lordon Miller uh who who make like the
Spider-Man Multiverse things and they
made the 21 Jump Street movies and uh
the Afterparty these guys are brilliant
and prolific and and so we're in a
Warner Brothers uh recording studio and
um and I were messing around and and and
the character had a song and so I start
I was just [__] around you know like
in a stoned way playing with voices and
we happened upon that voice
and they let me do it and I was I was so
grateful um that for once they I didn't
have to sound like this but to answer
your question so I don't I don't care if
it's funny or dramatic I was just
telling uh a friend I just I just signed
on to produce and and be a supporting
actor in an independent film that came
my way by a total unknown it's kind of
his first script and it's a [__]
hilarious brilliant script and I I got a
hold to the guy and I was like where the
[__] did you come from like this is
great yeah and I the reason I read
everything is because by God at some
point that [__] is going to show
up you never know and it's and it's so
inspiring and so my buddy and I are
going to help produce this movie um oh I
love that and it's and it makes you cry
and it's really funny it's a great
script so um when I when I was getting
offered those post Ron Swanson rolles I
talked to my agents and I said you know
what I'm just going to go to to my wood
shop and make some [__] and let's create
some daylight let's create a vacuum
because nature abhor that and sure
enough after a couple months of like
saying no to stuff Alex Garland called
me who made the movie
exmachina Annihilation movie to be in
Mak is like incredible it's incredible
it's a masterpiece he he for me he's
like the kubric of our day oh yeah and
uh or or if if you're a douche the C
brick of our day if you say beol
bris right but he he wanted to meet me
to do this Sci-Fi series called devs and
I was standing in my wood shop when I
got this call and I started crying I was
like it [__] worked like kubric
called me yeah you know I said no to all
the grill guys and now I get to do this
beautiful series although you have to
have a mustache in his movie um and talk
about it I did have a beard but I'm
pretty unre recognizable oh great yeah
and he didn't require it that was my
choice good that's it's cool that
scripts are still coming in cuz you know
you just we see the same Marvel and even
Top Gun like they do well and it's great
that theaters are still open and movies
are being made but it's nice to hear
when a just a great script comes through
you're like all right let's do this it
is it and it's interesting on on I'm
lucky enough to uh experience tastes of
both ends of the rainbow cuz I I a
supporting role in the uh Mission
Impossible movie that's coming out next
summer wow is another one which yeah
it's seven it's this this is eight eight
and it's the second half of seven so
it's it's called dead reckoning one and
two okay and those Chris mccy who makes
those he's made something like a dozen
movies with Tom Cat since like uh
Valkyrie and and that was so fascinating
cuz I don't ever work on that level on
big Studio things um what type of
character is it um I I'm not sure drill
uh yeah this guy it's a guy with a a
really masculine beard um he I I feel
like I'm trying to remember what has
been what's out there I I'm a uh I'm a
high I think I I can safely say I'm a
high up uh military presence gotcha um I
don't want you know I don't want to
do do you have scenes with Tom Cruz I
can't
remember was there a guy on an Apple box
to be honest but but the um but the
thing the thing was it I mean you know
it was [__] fascinating like these
guys while we were
shooting uh I don't know now I'm getting
confused in my years but at least a year
ago yeah it was a year ago a year and a
half ago while we're shooting the new
Top Gun came out with which our writer
director Chris mccy wrote wow and so he
and Tom uh you know are coming to work
every day and they're so we're working
shooting while their movie passed a
billion dollars in like a month so
they're feeling good and so there's that
sensibility of like they're really and
when they when when uh Chris mccy uh
they call him McHugh when he uh you know
set up a call to offer me to ask me to
come do the job his opening line I
hadn't met him so this is us meeting and
he said so this is really fun and he's a
really funny smart personable guy you
would think somebody like that would be
I don't know I feel like James Cameron
would be hard to talk to and he probably
is um because he he's openly said that
he doesn't like actors but oh really
really yeah what a weirdo uh sure I mean
they helped him make a billion dollars
cool he doesn't need them he just needs
computer versions of them right but
Chris mccy is incredibly personable so
we get on the phone and he was literally
in South Africa they had just shot you
know Tom Cruz like jumping off a [__]
rocket ship and um and he said Nick so
here's the deal uh here's how we make
these movies we jump out of an airplane
and we start sewing a parachute as we're
falling like we we know where we want to
get to we get all these people together
and and you know we start shooting and
we like literally make it up as we go
and so so I got my first pages of script
day one sitting in the hair and makeup
chair they brought me my first pages of
script so you don't know what you're
doing that's correct I mean I know I
know my character and I know the
circumstance but there and there's like
eight of us in this big scene and so we
all at the last minute are like hey nice
to meet you I'm just I'm learning my
lines as I'm about to go into my first
day you know working with with these
A-list actors and so it's very different
from all the theater and indie film [__]
that I'm that I'm used to but it's
fascinating and and it was interesting
because on a certain level you know you
can argue with their that they make very
successful that they're the best at what
they do yes well we need both exactly
and um and so I'm I feel very lucky that
I you know get to put my dip my toe into
the separate Waters yeah yeah I just
worried that the Indie is going away so
I'm glad like it's good to have a Pulp
Fiction and a forest gum you know but I
worry without DVD sales to maybe like
prop up an office space yeah we talk
about this all the time on the Pod we
love we love movies we love you know
obscure movies we love big budget stuff
too but but yeah I agree with Mark we we
need the kind of you need like a
sideways too yes you know totally 100%
and I and I I'm an optimist but I don't
think it can ever go away because that's
the one thing you can never replicate
like uh to each their own like I'm not
I'm not interested in [__] on Marvel
movies for example but but they're not
my bag and they and here's the and
here's the thing I mean I I've thought
about this quite a bit because I I
actually auditioned to play Wolverine
when wow and there there's a crazy story
that's hilarious uh Wolverine if he just
got
this was like this was 98 or 99 when
they when they made the first one and it
was um uh Brian Singer singer who made
yeah that's he's very friendly I've been
given to understand
um the they cast a can a Canadian actor
named Doug Ray Scott and he was doing a
mission impossible movie and they they
kept holding him too they wouldn't
release him and so Hugh Jackman got
flown in for day one without ever having
met Brian Singer so when he ended up of
course you know getting a lifetime
career of this role of Wolverine which
which he was incredible at and and I
remember hearing about it like who the
hell is Hugh Jackman this is x- this is
X-Men you know and now I'm like oh that
guy he's pretty good yeah he's I
remember the time my friends like it
should be Mel Gibson I was like yeah Mel
Gibson then 5 years later I was like
good thing it's not Mel Gibson yeah
thankfully yeah a different movie but
though uh I I was a big fight
choreographer for the stage I love sword
fighting and I I love combat I love
Jackie Chan like I love the sense of
swash Butler and it's something that I
miss uh in with modern CGI and editing
it's very rare that you see a cool
character with the Panache of like Jean
Kelly so if somebody's going to beat
somebody up very rarely do they likeing
like flip a prop and catch it and you're
like oh man they're [__] cool as hell
now it's all editing or it's CGI they do
something super cool but you know they
didn't really have to learn to do it
right and that to me personally uh when
CGI took over and it's not just the
Marvel movies which is like one one
Fantastical movies now Doctor Strange is
one that I love the comic but there's
nothing dror strange can do or Thanos or
you name it that I'm going to be like
how the [__] did they do that but if you
go back and watch Indiana Jones you're
like holy like you know those those
props those stunts are physical and real
yes the guy slides under the truck with
that Whip and all like all that [__]
you're like holy [__] you know that and
that's a big part of why Tom Cruz still
sells so well is because you know he's
doing that they show you here's Tom Cruz
jumping off a cliff on a motorcycle and
it's insane that he's still doing it it
really is I mean they really we saw a
bunch of footage cut together uh it was
on his 60th birthday oh my God what's he
running from how does he have that in
him still he could just put his feet up
in Barbados and take it easy um wh how
why is there a picture of me as
Wolverine oh we got a lot of windows
open that's pretty incredible what ises
he doing oh my god oh this apparently
the biggest stunt in movie
history who on
man I mean that's that's MCH God that's
my e to [__] my
pants come on man he did that Jesus and
they they showed us a bunch of footage
that uh that is going to be in in number
eight of them getting up to some Tom
Foolery with a couple of bipes oh I I
like straight blades and thank
thankfully we're I mean yeah they um
we're standing next to him and I and I I
was so tense from watching these
stunts uh that I I was like thank
goodness you're standing here because
otherwise there's no way somebody could
survive what he does in these things I
mean Jesse Smet must watch that and go
ah [__] I'm a hoax I'm a fraud yeah he's
really doing it it's true it's U and but
so that to me is why we'll never lose
the sense of of indie films that's why
you know we're on strike right now
partly because we have to get it in our
contract that you can't replace us with
AI which is I think pretty reasonable it
is but but of also you can just imagine
the capitalists like the the big story
that came out that they want to be able
to hire an extra and create by the way
this is uh a friend of mine worked on um
the the Fast and Furious where sadly
Paul Walker died in the middle of it and
they had to like create him
with four different guys and CGI to
finish the movie little weird and ever
since then she was a makeup artist and
she came back and said be careful
because from now on any big budget movie
is going to build a digital version of
you in case you die in a in an accident
right so it started with pure motives
and then yeah and yeah beware so now
producers for example want to be able to
hire an extra and build you so they hire
you and pay you for one day so extras
get [__] too yes 's $30 and a sandwich
and they build you and then they just
use that software for the run of the
movie wow and so it's it's extrapolate
that into like now some people argue the
other side of it where they're like well
if if you if you sell the Nick Offerman
software you could be making 10 movies
at once and make a lot of money and turn
into a bigger [__] than you already
are I you know I'm an i want to come
down on the side of artistry versus
Commerce and so I I insist that there
will never be anything approaching the
magic of a human being like like put a
person on stage and turn the lights on
and you can you you can't beat that
whether it's on screen or stage yes with
something computer generated it's F
phone sex versus real sex you know
there's always going to be a winner it's
was like [__] a sex doll it's not
even phone sex it's not a on the other
yeah oh yeah good point that's a good
point so and so the for for me once CGI
took over and Doctor Strange does the
most astonishing things I'm I'm still
left a little cold where I'm like yeah
but he didn't really do it did he and
also the Marvel stuff there's too many
of them like there literally like once
Disney plus took over and started making
like shows out of it I was like it it's
becoming insane like I I love Star Wars
growing up but there were three of them
now there's like all these extended
universes which is fine but you do take
away the magic I love The Sopranos I
didn't like the movie you know it just
it lost the magic for me I think
sometimes you take that time off too and
the magic's gone sure it'll be
interesting too to talk to like the Next
Generation uh because we both are
referencing early Indiana Jones or Star
Wars where I would argue that like the
weird [__] aliens at the nightclub
playing instruments the Cantina they
have the magic of the Muppets where you
know they exist in physical reality
right and if you give me a cartoon even
a a realistically rendered cartoon of
the Cantina it's I'm just not going to
I'm not going to feel the same pull yeah
but I wonder if like gen Z kids or
whatever I don't they care they don't
care they don't care I don't think they
care about artists I don't think they
like if an artist paints these you know
amazing paintings with a brush it's
different than doing it computer
generated they're just swiping they're
just scrolling I was at a museum earlier
looking at some wood working at an art
museum and there were these cool
artifacts on the wall that Drew my eye
and I was talking to the dosens uh and I
was like wow these are really cool I can
when you get up close you can see that
it's made out of plywood and they're
dyed pink and then I realized they were
made with a CNC a computer gen driven
router and I immediately was like this
is garbage like I I don't care about
this yeah yeah and it's it's nonetheless
it's I don't even mean I don't want to
fully denigrate uh but it lost the magic
of course it wasn't a sculpture it
wasn't sculpted it's yeah it's like when
we love standup comedy obviously when
you go oh he has writers you're kind of
like ah I thought it was out of his
brain his point of view when a comic has
writers we always lose a little respect
cuz you know I understand if you have a
TV show that's one thing but for your
standup if you have writers it's kind of
it loses the magic yeah I I understand
that powerfully I mean yes it's one
thing if you're doing a monologue every
night obviously sure who can do that but
but yeah if you're doing if you're
touring an hour that's that's your voice
you know makes a difference ex you want
Rodney you know you don't want the team
but yeah oh I had another thing [__] I
lost it Swanson no no want to do peeves
or anything yeah we should do peeves we
oh right we talk about our assignment oh
I did send in peeves and I even thought
of another one please uh oh uh does
anybody have what I sent in and I'll
pick between yeah we do have we'll pull
it up do them all oh I remember what I
want to say we'll fill the time I did
see the Indiana Jones new movie email
and the AI is unbelievable cuz they make
them look young and it's pretty
convincing I mean sure there's every
every conversation requires Nuance you
know there's good and bad to all of it
of course of course but the whole time
you're just watching going I can't
believe they pulled this off instead of
this is a good movie I mean I have I
have a book that I want to adapt me a
taste into a film and it's it's a guy's
life story and I can play the guy
probably from I'm 53 I you know with
makeup I could probably play the guy
from like 40 on sure sure but there's
there's some great scenes of the guy at
20 like riding a horse and he's a a
period farmer yeah and so even as I'm
conceptualizing the movie I'm like do I
what do I do and I and I think I would
rather cast try and cast somebody close
to me I think that's cooler though you
get two performances like they did that
movie on Brian Wilson and you get John
qac playing him older and Paul do and
now you get two great performances right
right I understand that that that is
costing the studio more money but I
think it made the movie so much better I
I agree and I I'm trying to get qack to
play the
young keep going younger we'll
see Joan Cusack there we go while I'm
stretching for time here Mark you can
you share with him the story from Conan
that you shared earlier oh yeah well
just it was you had a great line I met
you for eight seconds like a rodeo and
uh I was in they didn't like my outfit
so they had to give me a button down to
wear so I was in a robe and you walked
by and said shave the boy and send him
to my room and I got a huge laugh in the
room and that was it fantastic so always
fun when you can get a zing in I
remember that
that and that I mean that um that's like
a Mel Brooks thing or something Have him
shaved and sent to my room oh really
yeah we got it killed yeah I don't some
of Nick's peeves here um people cutting
off in traffic is the first
one um yeah well let's jump to number
three podcasts of aimless
chatting which um which which I is is I
thought might get a laugh but also is
for real like
it's a thing so now every I mean for
years now everyone has a podcast of
course and the like I've and and I enjoy
them or despise them like anybody like
anything you know I love some country I
hate some country music MH
but when when I when I when there are
people that I like and I'm like oh cool
I'm going to check out their podcast and
you tune in and they're like hey here I
am in my my garage in Denver with my two
friends and they proceed to talk about a
laundry anecdote for the first 28
minutes I've done that one and I'm like
with a like I don't you I don't know
what the percentage is but it's people
who don't think they're cuter than they
are totally totally where it's like hey
I [__] love your you drew me to your
podcast now at least drive towards some
content like yes and it's it's before
they bring their guest out and it's uh
you know I mean it's a crazy stat but
they say I think 2% of podcasts make it
past 20 episodes oh that's wild so it's
wildly like we're in the way way upper
echelon just with a certain amount of
episodes well dude the amount of PODS
that will do that it it is insane and
that's why we try to have some structure
at this but uh it's what a good mix but
you're you're intelligent curious people
and so the conversations you didn't do
half an hour before I got here that's
that's what kills me we did like 15
minutes I thinkes yeah just to build it
up but but you but you're driving
towards something like you guys are
interested in the world it's not it's
it's Naval gazing that where and and
when a pod even podcast of people that I
love if there's three hosts I'm always
like I don't want to do that podcast CU
I'm like I'm not going to get to talk
yeah yeah that's why we don't let them
talk funny yeah would you mind going in
the
hallway
but here's something I want to touch on
because I want there's a little bit of a
PSA to it because it just happened to me
again and this is a little bit rarified
all right be because it involves uh
funko pop dolls Funko po but but it
doesn't have to but for me specifically
here's here's the peeve autograph people
now do a thing oh I've seen these they
uh they now do a thing uh where they
find out they have people on the inside
side at Airlines uh put in uh see how
many Ron Swanson ones you can find
please
uh they have people at the airline I've
seen this and they find out when you're
flying in to Philly to Cleveland to
Vancouver and they [__] hit you at
baggage claim oh they get in somehow
they're they're for these dolls they
want you to sign them yeah so there's at
least there are at least eight of these
there eight versions of Ron Swanson wow
Ron pretty good it's yeah that's that's
uh pillbox hat dancing Ron but baggage
claim is already held you've gotten off
the flight now you're waiting and yeah
the bag so specifically for me because
because these and and I really would
like to maybe do some homework to find
out what are you actually getting for a
funko pop that I've signed because these
guys show up and it's always big bearded
guys yes and there way they're keeping
it right or no it's clearly like it's
openly cuz they have several they have a
bag of stuff a good way to ruin that for
them is let me make it out to you well
no I I try that but they they they get
around it they have learned 800 clams
holy [__] I mean you could get a real
job for the amount of work it takes to
go to the airport get in get these Funko
what I say to them so so a please do I I
basically a long time ago even before
these do I began saying
to professional autograph people cuz
they also meet you outside of Letterman
or Co bear and and when they have it
taped off and it's obviously going to a
collector like like a sale I just say I
don't want to encourage this like you're
a parasite and I'm friendly about it but
I'm like what the [__] are you doing
with your life like how long are you
hanging out here at baggage claim and
how much are you to roll the dice that
you can sell something I signed and I
always think of my wife who's who is
much more of like a sex symbol and like
where I'm like I don't want to encourage
you to do this because then you're going
to do it to people like my wife who
couldn't beat you up good point and and
cuz sometimes they show up at your hotel
and I'm like don't please don't like I'm
not going to I'm not going to
participate in this and I did it
recently and these guys in Philly got in
my face whoa and I said I said listen
let's just take a breath and and look at
like take step back you're getting upset
with me cuz I won't sign your
doll and this and and these guys are in
Phil full fully uh Philadelphia Phillies
gear wearing their jerseys and their
hats and this guy gets up in my face
this sad Philly fan and was like Hey man
we know where your show is like we know
where your hotel is like like have fun
have fun getting safe to your hotel
tonight the saddest tough guys ever like
terrorist wow man I and I you know I got
my phone out and I'm like videoing the
whole thing yeah and I went over to this
tiny security guy they're talking to a
mob boss he didn't sign the [__] doll
Hey where's he didn't sign it get Jimmy
get in here where's my where's my Funko
Pop I went and found a tiny Asian
elderly security guy and was like hey
these guys like you know and they were
already gone yeah he's like I love fun
but the the the the PSA is please don't
go to the [__] baggage claim and ask
people to sign your [__] like get a job
like like do something with your life
that's so sad and I had a weird
situation in Toronto a few weeks ago it
was like a really fun gig I was playing
the Meridian Hall theater it was really
exciting and I'm it's part of the JFL
Festival so I'm going in after Jenna
Fischer and Angela kin Kenny they're
doing their podcast before me in the
venue so the fans out there are hoping
to meet them and then they turn to me
like once they saw once one person
recognized me they're like oh autograph
and I'm like you don't I don't want to
be your sloppy second you know it's like
you hit on the girl at the bar she
wasn't there you come to me but I I
signed him but he signed the Jif fish I
signed Angela kiny here yeah have you
ever seen the king of comedy great movie
Dao's profession in that movie AER
pupkin he's an autograph seeker and he
oh that's right SS him
damn yeah yeah but but he then he makes
[Laughter]
it the worst people always make it yeah
that's the moral that story well we have
a Funko here no I mean you got another
another peeve here with the
the what is it the oh airport stadiums
named after corporations oh that's a
great one that's a great one we're going
to noia to see the Super Bowl it's so
sadly American I mean we've we we've are
fty to our corporations is so complete
that the poor white socks are now
playing in Guaranteed Rate field oh or
the Padres play in Petco Park where it's
it's like look I understand that you
have to slather advertising across every
available inch around the baseball field
so I'm watching Joey vad or like I'm
watching some hero and it's like you
know Hefty Hefty Hefty where I'm like
this can't can't I have my baseball I
grew up in New Orleans we had the Super
Dome that was like our pride and joy and
now it's the mercedesbenz super doome
they did a great joke about this in uh
baseball where they were playing at Maxi
tampon
Arena love that well the story Lakers
now play in crypto.com Arena well before
it was the Staple Center it wasn't like
it Staples kind of works but yeah well
Staples cuz there's there's a great R&B
group so you can mistake us for like the
Staple Center I'll take better than the
R Kelly Center Office Depot uh The
Office Depot Arena or something there's
an Office Depot on which sounds like the
saddest [__] place in a strip mall
not not a place where a team plays it is
I mean and so so you know don't just
complain offer a solution my solution is
get together understand that if you can
have class with your corporation it's
probably going to help your sales like I
would argue I I don't know that the
Staple Center is like um by the way I
need some three-hole paper where where
should we stop I know does it really
work after the game oh that's a good
point you well I got to next week I'm
doing the Funko Center which is super
annoying but yeah no that's a great one
it's so true it just it strips it with a
it's a little less dignity a little less
fun it's just corporations all day I
love the Cubs I mean I'm a life on Cubs
fan my my whole big family in Illinois
and we love going to Wrigley Field and I
I love uh singing the stretch and
throwing out the first pitch and um did
you throw a strike uh I have not thrown
a strike yet I I threw a ball and then
I've done it two more times and I one
time I had my cousin do it maybe I I
don't or then the other time I had my
dad do it oh fun um cuz we we we bring a
bus with like 24 people um so yeah I I
didn't I did a whole bit with my Dad we
plan this thing where we come out and he
and I we we plan this thing where we
shake hands and I do an elaborate
stretching and then I I get lined up
like I'm going to throw to center field
and he's like no no no no no other way
great and so we spent all the time doing
the bit and then I didn't like get
settled before throwing the pitch cuz
I'm a like you know I got I practiced
for like a month you got to practice you
don't have a fouchy but uh it it's
something that that I greatly enjoy and
I love listening to both the TV guys and
the radio guys we have this great guy
named Pat Hughes and Ron cumer on the
radio and so quite often I never have
the luxury where I can sit and watch a
game but so quite often like I'll be at
my wood shop or I'll be doing getting
something done so I listen to the radio
more than I have the TV guys and the and
both of them it just it cracks me up I
mean you could Christopher Guest could
do a whole movie about it where where
they're like okay and you know here's
Nico Herer comes to the plate uh the
plate is sponsored by Solo cups and
every single thing has a scripted line
that that they can't get through an
inning without hitting like eight
endorsements just like guys and they're
great at casually just like throwing
them out there but I'm like God damn it
why can't can't you disgusting anyway
this podcast is brought to you
by.com I will to piggy back on your uh
your peeve I will say with stadiums
enough with the the music every 2
seconds they all right everybody here we
go how do you feel about this we're
doing the Hokey pokei now we're doing
that like let me just enjoy it I went to
a soccer or football game in uh London I
went to Arsenal there's none of that
it's just game beer it's all it's all
for the kids that's why that's what it
is it's not for the adults anymore it's
but I I would offer in in British in
European football uh or footy yeah the
thing that I envy them is in America we
we get drunk uh as a group and just
scream violence and filth and and we're
we're fully prepared to fight each other
and and your kids I'll beat your [__]
kid up if he's wearing the wrong
Jersey in in English football they have
a culture that that predates like is
ancient where the entire Stadium will
sing songs together yes and they're
clever and they're B and sometimes
they're hor
horrible yeah but they're but my
favorite was and and everyone knows
everyone joins in immediately so instead
of just like you know da D D D D like
we're kindergarteners the whole stadium
is singing to the other team your
support is [__] [__] yes where like
everyone on Moss and it's it's this it
feels like a gladiator Arena yes exactly
and it just it's still drunken and
boisterous but it's like you you're you
and your team sucks in a in a in a group
it feels neighborly yeah instead of just
like literate even the cheers feel kind
of corporate in a weird way they're not
but oh here it now you know the other
thing is every Sports gambling was
illegal what three years ago now every
DraftKings FanDuel bet MGM it's insane
how it went from illegal to like is this
mandatory do I have to bet on the game
now right and again it's in in the
channels that you're watching and listen
to with your kids which I don't have
kids but I mean it's [__] gambling
like you you know we we've learned not
to have me come on like selling Mar Bros
like we're like okay that's [__] in
every way and now suddenly gam like you
and you even have athletes you have
baseball players being like hey it's me
whatever I can't think of which one was
on so I don't want to say the wrong one
but it's it's me Pete
Rose and the time about time we forgave
him I'm putting 50 bucks on you know
that would be great in the middle of
watching it on TV and I'm I think that's
upsetting yeah well we act like this is
a new thing I mean they used to have
like the Vita Comedy Hour you know or
the the penoil variety show brought to
you by Chester Fields there you go you
made me think of a bit I'm working on I
don't know if there's more here can I
try a bit sure so this was you're
talking about the fighting at the game
or the you know the the drink the
drinking the game but like every
football game now it's like I I watch
the NFL and it's like every week There's
a fight there'll be women fighting and
my angle one of my angles I want to try
is um you know it's always a dude losing
the fight who's in the opposing Jersey
yeah I'm like you're the do you not
realize you're the only one wearing
green what do you so I think my angle is
like that's not where you pick a fight
I'm a Jew I'm not walking into a mosque
like any of you [__] like
Islam Let's Dance that's that's I'm
going to try it tonight going in
outnumbered read the room read the room
exactly but on the flip side the mosque
guy will go into the the synagogue with
the dynamite vest you're like that's how
you do it right that's how you win
against you win that's right hundreds I
can I do let me do a peeve too I wrote
hit me with a peeve I think I got a
peeve as I got a peeve um hold on hold
on don't leave Nick um oh I gotta peeve
how about this people
uh I when people say uh I'm going to
make an executive decision that's a
[__] it's never like it's always at
like uh you're like a [__] restaurant
you're not you're not running a Fortune
500 you want to order chicken fingers I
[__] hate that
[__] a bit maybe that's a bit I don't
know look you guys take your time
ordering but I'm going to make an
executive
decision can we get two guacs and one
salsa for the table
please all right I got how about this
one this one's weird I can't wrap my
head around this one I'm in a store I'm
kind of lost and I go up to a guy and I
go hey man do you work here and he flips
he's like [__] you I don't work here
what do you think I work here and I'm
like what's so bad about working here I
don't get why that's it's the biggest
insult always a dude wearing a blue polo
at Best Buy too it was a guy in a red
shirt at Target like you're wearing a
red shirt it's always like you can't you
can see why I made the mistake yes and
wouldn't it be worse if you were like
what if he was like I do yeah you got me
I think I mean yeah I think it it it
Taps into the stereotypes perhaps that
we're afraid of like like I'm trying to
think of where would I be that I'd have
that reaction maybe at Chi andales or be
like no [__] Thunder Down Under I have a
BFA yeah yeah that job that's a
compliment though to like do you work
here I suppose yeah that's not a great
example but um you're kind of insulting
the people who do work here by getting
that angry yeah exactly I mean also have
people say it to me I don't give a [__]
I'm like oh no I don't but sometimes I'm
like I the bathroom's that way yeah try
to help I'm I'm in the comedy cell
people are like I'm like why don't I'm
not the bouncer but I'll [__] I'll
show you where the bathroom is yeah why
not I I don't get why I got so angry I
don't work here but I do I can't tell a
[__] Philip's head from a standard so
what can I do for him there you go Home
Depot so do you have any uh do you have
any wrecks Nick oh yeah um I do I uh I
mean I tell you what I'm listening to
right now uh the the premier short story
writer in our country right now is named
George Saunders he's amazing I like
George Santos he's got really great St
he also is great at
fiction George uh he and he he won uh
the man Booker prize for his one novel
uh called Lincoln and the Bardo but
here's the wreck um go onto your
channels and listen to listen to him
read his own stuff for being the
preeminent like the the scholarly you
know short story writer who studied
under bias wolf at Syracuse and now he
teaches at Syracuse he sounds he sounds
like the most downto earth like Chicago
guy yeah and if you listen to him read
his stuff and my wreck to to give you an
appetizer uh speaking of guac is a story
of his called Fox 8 okay it's a short
story um if you can read along because
there's some tricks to the way it's
written that are visual but you hear him
read his stuff and he's just so funny
and Brilliant and most of all I learn
empathy from him uh he also has this
great commencement speech that came out
as a as a little book called
Congratulations by the way and so these
are these are short takes but I'm
telling you he's so funny it but uh but
it's also medicinal so all right this
graduation speech is is basically just
about kindness which again like my soil
material it doesn't sound like super
sexy and funny but he's he's just a hero
to me uh the way that he um in the same
way that Mike Sure uh exudes kindness
with his television comedy yeah uh
George does it with his fiction but it's
not corny kindness either it's like it's
like it feels sincere I think some shows
do the they they kind of beat you over
the head with it where it just doesn't
even feel real didn't he write the thing
about the two test subjects who were
having sex yeah yeah what's that called
again it was so good well um is it is it
the one that uh Hemsworth made into a
movie I didn't see the movie but I I
yeah I think so yeah it's called like uh
pull it up Saunders sex test subjects
having
sex yeah Escape or something it was
escape from
something it's so good it's so funny and
weird and like and his um his big uh
number one no spiderhead SP it's really
good um get blown by eight women yeah
it's so his stuff is is kind of
futuristic but but really benal and
funny so for example in the future where
there are like theme parks like we have
Colonial Williamsburg there will be
future things where people are like
live things are so shitty that some
people live in the theme park and they
their job in their life is they live as
like a cave dweller oh interesting and
so it's like normal Bal language of like
okay day
721 the you know the the green food
paste is blah blah blah and like you
fall you fall in love with your
cooworker so he he takes the banality of
daily life and then just gives it the
most incredible Stakes of of of love and
loss and it it's and hearing him read
his own stuff even though he he has this
like really Everyman voice is just
gorgeous I'm listening I'm relising
right now to his book uh the 10th of
December which is like there's a one of
the best stories in
it uh called the the something diaries
simpli for Diaries or something like
that um it's cool in the future to order
Asian girls and you string them up in
your yard and they and they do it with
like uh uh glass fibers that that feed
them and sustain their their life and
it's a it's a it's a status thing so the
more girls you have on your clothes line
and so it's just people trying to deal
with like we do [__] that weird as a
society where it's like I I have large
hoops in my earlobes or it's just
extrapolating to the nth degree so it's
people trying to deal with the the
reality of like are they okay like is
this is this is this not [__] up and
the the the um the sophisticates are are
like what are you talking about like we
are leaders in this community we have 17
girls Yeah in our yard interesting it's
really funny no he's really I've read
some of his stuff and he's amazing I I'm
definitely going to check this out and
and there was another book you sent uh
the Walter Berry thing I saw you talk
about in the news wendle Berry I I just
ordered it I'm I'm curious now but uh
yeah know I love George Saunders what
I've read so I'm going to check out this
book wendle berberry uh is uh I had
lunch with him yesterday in Kentucky he
he is my hero who I also have befriended
he and his wife Tanya and they have a
farming program and if you want to know
what's going on with our country and uh
where our food comes from and and how we
should be paying attention to our
Farmers agreed uh start with his book uh
the unsettling of America which you can
hear an audio version in a voice that
sounds a lot like this one right
here um and then also uh sort of
dovetailed with him is Michael pollen's
omnivores dilemma oh it's that uh these
books are incredible where you'll never
be able to go to the grocery store the
same again where and and all it comes
down to is beginning to understand which
food is good for you and which isn't
which is being made for a profit rather
than for nutritional value oh we need
that stuff cuz I went to Europe for a
month I I can't eat bread here I feel
horrible I eat bread over there I was
fine it's incredible I mean just because
they because they didn't let industrial
consumerism take over yes some of their
food systems they do so like their
capitalists desperately want to become
American like you know there are
factions in grocery stores yeah because
you get rich and they're like [__]
nutrition like [__] your family yes I'm
I'm making money I know it's terrify
I've been drinking tap water my whole
life then you see all this stuff about
fluoride and you're like Jesus what are
you doing to the the American people so
I yeah I don't I don't have great comedy
wrecks but I have great life hack wrecks
I got a good movie Wreck for you guys
sometimes I'll just watch it be on the
road around like a flight and I'll just
watch like old Cisco and eert uh from
the 90s there's there's something so
calming about watching they're so good
together was it night at the theater
what do they call it I don't remember
the name of the show but it's but
they're just together passionate and
great and one of the movie wrecks that
they threw out at the movies movies at
the movies they threw out a movie wreck
that I was like all right this sounds
good let me watch it it's called Red
Rock West with Nicholas Cage and Dennis
Hopper it's so [__] good it's like a
weird obscure Noir from the 9s highly
recommend really loved it I'm in love it
check it out it's really cool it's
Dennis Hopper being a psycho and
Nicholas Cage being you know Nicholas
Cage it's really cool with probably some
gorgeous Utah scenery yeah it's it's
awesome David lynchy a little bit uh
it's you know who did it that guy John
do what else did you do last seduction
oh that a pretty cool movie and I mean
you know for for the sake of uh Fair
Play Let's do our caps to Laura Flynn
Bole she's awesome and I love Flyn Bole
she can do comedy too yeah I mentioned
this to Colin Quinn yesterday and he was
like I used to know her she's very cool
oh yeah yeah she was in Men In Black y
another a book wreck too if you if cuz
this coming out this weekend so uh
killer a flower Moon read that before
the movie comes out the book is [__]
incredible so highly recommend oh is
that the Scorsese yeah the movie is
coming out this month but uh the book is
insane it's like a true crime it's like
a true crime a Noir a murder mystery
it's it's incredible I I blew me away so
I'm reading his other book his newer
book now but uh David gr incredible
writer this and the a Napoleon Movie I'm
like jerking off I can't wait walking
Phoenix is Napoleon I am going be so
cool I know I hope I hope that that is
pressing me as Teddy
Roosevelt please please God yes well we
know you we know you have to get what
what show are you doing
next um great question oh what where am
I going next uh I have the rest of the
day
off the the next two days I'm doing a
bunch of like the view and uh Today Show
and um Seth Meyers I was supposed to do
Co bear but I got uh bumped when the
strike ended they were like we're going
to do way bigger cooler [__] than have
you on with your paperback so so they
shunted me to Seth Meers who you know is
a real champagne problem right like oh
no I I got have to do another Prime Time
network show well check out Nick's book
The we're big fans and the audio book he
does it and we have some dates for the
Comedy Tour oh humorous tour oh right on
okay oh the eighth so we have uh Los
Angeles on the seventh um then we have
Windsor Ontario on October 19th then
you're up in uh Prior Lake Minnesota
which I've never heard of just outside
the Twin Cities I've played that casino
before it's a that's a nice Casino I
love it and then uh Brooks California on
October 21st outside of Sacramento and
then on to Baltimore that's a great
Baltimore legendary room that's north of
Miami D wow that's a good spot good room
guys drink our Boda cat whisky boat
whiskey.com thank you so much Nick for
coming on man my pleasure thanks for
having me gentlemen great Scotch all
right all right thank you man good app
what an app guys you could see me on
tour I'll will be uh November 4th at the
theater at Madison Square Garden that's
a big one there's still some some
tickets available also uh late October
you could see me in Pittsburgh
Cincinnati
Indianapolis uh Columbus Cleveland and
then I will be all over Australia
November uh you could see me in Tampa
Fort Meyers Vegas at the win in December
uh Philly in January I mean I'm going to
be everywhere truly everywhere so a blue
room in uh Springfield Missouri December
28th through 30th Buffalo as well your
hometown mat uh in
uh December all over Omaha Dallas Dania
Beach uh Madison Oklahoma City
Dallas uh Irvine California Salt Lake
City and that's all leading up to my
special which will be on sale later this
month in Boston in March so see you on
the road now go to
Marks Mark Norman you could see this guy
everywhere man he's got to get bigger F
his
website see October starting yeah you
got to go to the to the city though all
right zoom in on the city zoom in on the
city yeah right there Hershey Tacoma
Oklahoma City Mark Norman you can see
him in Dallas Portland Maine Providence
Cleveland he's going to be in Grand
Rapids Denver two shows in Denver look
at that [__] Grand Junction Colorado
yeah Hartford Hartford
Connecticut what's at the bottom new H
Conquer New Hampshire Mobile Alabama and
Hometown hero norleans
she's got a piss so I started reading
yours oh all right I'm ready what else
you got
there two shows Omaha Kansas City norfol
Baltimore Birmingham shreport Tampa
Jacksonville Columbus Ohio Indianapolis
Lexi in Kentucky Charlotte we don't have
to do the whole Mark Norman comedy.com
new dates added you don't say tour come
on by it's going to be a h a new hour
hell yeah same here I'm gearing up for
that one at sam.com SL shows by Bodega
cat whiskey at bodegacat whiskey.com
Nick Offman was awesome great up and
thanks for listening guys hell yeah B
cat all right let's bring weenie down
weenie all
[Music]
right
be a
too and Norman's talking [__] [__]
and I get down in the
Way Up on the Roof like a cop coming and
naked Samu is feeling
danger I'm out to lunch here in New
Orleans this woman doesn't look like I
remember and I get down in the same
way we
might
be